WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So my
name is Wayne Piekarski,
and I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
And so today we're going to
be talking about developing
applications for Android Wear.
So we're going to do
a bit of introduction,
show you how Wear
works, and then we're
going to get into
some of the real nuts
and bolts of the
wearable support library,
some of the things that make
developing for Wear unique.
So as I said, I'm a
developer advocate at Google,
and I work mainly in the areas
of Android and Ubiquitous
computing.
So we work on a lot of
the new form factors
that Google's working
on, such as wearables
and auto and Brillo
and Weave and so forth,
so we're doing a lot of
those things like that.
So that's kind of
what I work on.
And another thing I'm
really excited about
is, I'm at this Android
barbecue, so I was like,
well you know what, I should
share my breakfast sausage
recipe with everyone as well.
So here's my little
recipe for it,
and if you go to my
Google plus page,
which is
google.com/+WaynePiekarski,
you can see my recipe.
Now this is like my favorite
breakfast sausage I've ever
worked out how to make.
So you can use it for chicken
fried steaks, biscuits
and gravy, and
it's really simple.
You take your own ground pork
and can you mix it up, and then
you fry it up in a pan.
You know, make sure you
use a non nonstick pan.
You've got to use one
of those old school
pans like a cast iron skillet
or something like that.
And then you put some flour
in there and you make a roux.
And then when you're
done, you can pour it
over biscuits and
gravy, or you can put it
on some of the
chicken fried steak,
or all those kinds of things.
Yeah so that's my talk so
I guess we're done now,
so we can all go home right?
Yeah so I think since we're
at the big Android barbecue,
I probably should
share that with you.
All right.
Let's get back on track here.
So we are into
Android Wear today.
So look at this picture here.
We've got a bunch of
people standing around,
and they're all looking
at their phones,
and they all appear--
they're kind of disengaged
from each other.
And we see this a lot nowadays.
Like people go out
with their friends
and no one's actually
talking to anyone,
they're busy on their
phones doing stuff.
And so we've been looking
at this kind of usage
and we're like, what could
we do to make things better?
So we know that phones
and tablets are useful,
but it seems like
we're disconnected
from the people around us.
So Android Wear aims to sort
of complete that picture,
and you can see here in
this photo everyone's
happy having a great time.
This is what happens
when use Android Wear.
Anyway, just kidding.
What it does is it helps
you stay in the moment
with the people
that are around you.
So it keeps you in a moment
when it's appropriate,
but it gives you the information
you need when you need it,
and it tries to avoid the
distraction of pulling
your phone out of your
pocket and constantly
being distracted.
So let's look at this
in a different way.
This is how it looks
like when use your phone
on a day to day basis.
You're doing real
life, then something
happens, you pull your
phone out, you unlock it,
you read some notification,
oh, OK, and then you're, oh,
there's a news article,
I'll start reading that.
And the next thing you know,
five minutes of your life
has disappeared, and there's
this huge time and attention
cost that it's
imposed on you to be
able to use this kind of thing.
So you might want to be
distracted in your device,
but you also might be very
busy amongst your friends,
and this isn't really
what you want to be doing.
So with Android Wear, we're
attempting to change that.
So there's your day,
start chugging along,
something happens, you
quickly look at your watch
and go, oh, cool I
better take that,
or it's not that
important I'll skip.
So it allows you to
have a quick look,
quick glance at your watch.
It has an always-on
display that's
always showing
something, and it helps
you to reduce the
overhead of being
notified about things that are
going on in the real world.
And so it allows you to be
more present in the real world,
but yet more connected to the
virtual world with the things
that are important to you.
So what does this mean for
your development of apps?
So to start with, it's a very
different interaction model.
So with Android Wear
you can see we have
a range of different devices.
There are round displays,
there are square displays,
the screen's really
small, and if you
want to get a really good user
experience on wearable devices,
you really need
to rethink the way
that you program for it
and the way you use it
and everything else.
So one thing people
like to do, is
they like to say, well I'm just
going to take my phone app,
and sort of jam it on
to the wearable screen
and make it really tiny.
But that's not really
what you want to be doing.
So the way you should
think about designing apps
for wearables is
to say to yourself,
what couldn't we do on the
phone that a wearable device now
makes possible?
And that's the kind of app
you should be building.
And I think the killer app for
wearables in general is coming,
and it's going to be
made by one of you people
here, a developer
who's like, you
know what, I have this
really amazing idea
and it's going to
change the world.
When Android and iPhones
came out many years ago,
everyone thought they're just
going to be browsing the web
and checking their
email, and now we've
got all these exciting apps
that people use that they
couldn't live without.
Those are the killer apps
that define the platform.
And so the killer app for Wear
can be created just by you
because it's an open platform.
And the next thing is that
when you build a wearable app,
you have to actually try it.
So you can't just run it on an
emulator on a massive desktop
screen with a mouse, you have
to actually put it on your wrist
and go for a run,
and while you're
jogging you should try to
use your app by touching
the screen.
That's when you'll discover
if your little buttons are
too small or if there's
some kind of problem
with how you're doing things.
So you're going to get
yourself in the situation
and try it just like
a user would do.
And so it's just things
that make Wear different.
So this here is the
Android Wear interface.
And so you can see
that we have-- there's
no grid of icons to launch.
It's simple, it's
glanceable, and it's
built around micro
interactions, these very quick
little gestures.
You can look at your
watch in the corner.
You don't have to use it
like you do with a phone.
And the interface is divided
up into two primary behaviors.
So we have the ability
to talk to the wearable.
Use your voice.
You say, OK, Google,
send a message.
So you talk to the watch
to make it do things.
So we call these actions.
And then the next
thing is that once
you say, OK, Google, it then
shows you a list of commands
that are possible.
So you can do things
like take a note,
call me a ride,
things like that,
and these are the things
that are available to you.
Now, the wearable can send
information back to you
as well.
So we have these notification
cards that pop up.
So we call this
the context stream.
And so there's a variety
of different things
that the wearable can send to
you to show you on the screen.
Are you ready for the trip?
You have a flight to JFK
coming up, your hotel
information, things like that.
This is stuff that
you're walking around,
and your watch will
vibrate and you're like,
oh, I've got to
get to the airport.
So it's telling you things
that are important right
now in the right place.
We don't want to tell someone
about something that's
happening eight hours from now.
You want to tell them about
something that's right now
and it's important.
So this is the framework
that helps you to set you up
for success on Android Wear.
So if you want to make a
really good application,
you have to carry this
philosophy into your apps
as well.
So for example, you have
to build wearable apps that
are aware of the users' context,
their time, their location,
their physical activity.
That card bearer is
aware of the fact that
going to take you 15 minutes to
get home right now because you
put something in your
calendar that tells you
that you need to
be home by then.
A watch is also designed to
tell time in a split second.
So when a user uses
a traditional watch,
they just look at, know what
the time is, and they're done.
And during this talk I'm
going to glance at my watch
multiple times to find out
how I'm going for time.
And so it's very quick.
Your not seeing me pulling
my phone out and unlocking it
and checking the time.
And so if you can check
the time in a split second,
you should also be
able to check whatever
is going on in a split second.
So here it's like turn right
onto Washington Street.
This is a direction
right now, this
is something you have to do.
And it's very quick
and easy and there's
an arrow pointing to
where you need to go.
You can think of
Android Wear as kind
of like a personal assistant.
You ask it to do things, and it
does the right thing for you,
and it just gets it right.
So here it's got, send a
note to Jeff, I'm on my way.
So these are very
simple actions you want
and it would be
the kind of thing
that if you had a
friend next to you, hey,
can you send a message to
Jeff, tell him I'll be there
in five minutes,
that's something
your friend could do for you.
It's a personal assistant
that's designed to help you.
And finally you've got to focus
on very simple interactions.
You've got only require
input when it's necessary.
You should try to do the
right thing automatically.
And most inputs are going to
be done with touches or swipes,
and because the screen is very
small you have to make sure
that you've got very large
touch targets, things
that are easy to click
while a person is running,
like we talked about before.
So you want to avoid
fine-grained finger movements.
You don't want to have
tiny little keyboards
and things like that.
So when you design your
Android Wear experience,
you've got to keep these
kind of things in mind.
So with that, now
we're going to talk
about the nuts and
bolts of how we
go about building applications.
I really wanted to sort of set
the stage for how this works,
because it helps to understand
that with Android Wear,
the UI is probably the
most important thing.
How it interacts with
the user is everything.
You can't write
good code for this
until you've seen how it works.
All right.
So let's go through
three topics now.
We're going to talk about
how to do notifications,
how to make your
own watch faces,
and then how to design
your own full blown
apps that run on Wear.
So the first is notifications.
Now, the cool thing
about notifications
is that if you have a
notification on your phone,
they're automatically
sent over to the wearable
by the wearable companion app.
So any standard
Android notification
works for free on Android
Wear and you don't really
need to do anything.
Then you can extend
them to add features,
but you don't need to.
So to get this done,
there's no work required.
They're just automatic.
Also if you've implemented the
meteor API's or remote control
client, the actual
controls for those
are automatically sent
to the wearable as well.
So any standard
music playing app,
when you're playing
music on your phone,
you'll see a notification
on you wearable
that you can use to change
tracks, pick a different song,
and things like that.
And to get this done, once
again, no work required.
Now, if you want to implement
slightly more complicated
notifications, we
have some extensions
that we've added
to notifications.
So we have stacks,
pages, and replies,
which allow you to make slightly
more complicated notifications
that'll appear in a special
way on the wearable,
but they'll still be regular
notifications on a phone.
And you can add these features
and it won't break your app,
even if your app is needed
to run on a Gingerbread phone
or something like that.
So these extensions allow
you to add a little bit more
to notifications to make
them slightly more useful.
The really cool
part is you don't
need to do anything to
your app except adding
a couple extra lines of code
in your notification section,
and your app is already
sort of on the way
there for Android Wear support.
So it's really nice thing
about notifications.
Later on, we're going
to talk about how
to write full apps, which are
a very complete Android Wear
experience.
This is a great
way to get started.
So if you are already an
existing Android web developer,
you can easily add some
quick Android Wear support.
Have a think about
it, try it out,
and then you can
go the whole way
if you decide that's
important for you.
So watch faces are probably
one of the most exciting things
that people love to talk about.
So you can see
we've got a watch.
The watch face is the screen
that is running on the watch
all the time.
So, when the user is
not using the screen,
it is showing the
watch face, and you
can load many different
watch faces onto a device.
You download them
by the Play Store
and it's probably the most
important part of a user's
Android Wear experience.
And you as an app
developer have the ability
to make your own watch
faces of any kind.
Analog, digital,
whatever you want.
And so this is something
that people are really
particular about.
People like a watch face
that's designed for them.
I like a digital watch
face that-- oops--
I like a digital watch face in
orange, a lot of people don't.
They like analog watch faces.
So everyone's got a
different taste here.
So there's a lot of
opportunity to make
some really cool watch
faces that really
change the way we tell time.
So I'm going to talk to
you a little bit more
about the API's that
are used to do this.
So, with a watch
face, of course,
the most important
thing is that it
has to actually tell the time.
So make sure you
always have that.
It would be kind of silly
to make a watch face that
shows a cloud and it's
saying it's raining outside
but doesn't actually
tell the time.
So people are probably
not going to like that.
So you've got to make
sure you put that in.
So you can use analog
hands like in this case,
or you could put a digital
representation on top of it.
Or you could use some other
kind of representation
like you could print
it in binary or hex
or whatever it is that you
think your developers want.
So, you can do that too.
Now, there's a status bar area.
So you can see
there's a little alarm
bell with a stroke through it.
That's telling you that
notifications and alarms
have been suppressed.
So these are going to be put
on the screen by the system,
and you need a place on your
screen for those to appear.
So you can own the whole watch
face and draw what you want,
but the system also needs to
put a few icons here and there
that you need to make room for.
And also notification
cards are going
to pop up in the stream
on top of the watch face.
So you need to be prepared
to deal with them.
So what you can do
in some cases is
you can resize your watch
face to not be under the card.
In other cases, you
can also control
how much the card pops
up and things like that.
So you've got control over all
these things as part of the API
for it.
And you could also
add other things
such is the time of day,
the current weather.
A lot of the Android
Wear watch faces
that are out, show things
like showing details
from your calendar, showing the
weather, the tides, the moon,
whatever you want.
So you can have
different watch faces
for different kinds
of people depending
on what they want to do.
So here are a few guidelines to
make sure you get this right.
So the first thing
is that Android Wear
comes in multiple form factors.
So if you're designing
a watch face,
you really want it to run on
both round and square watches.
So it would be
kind of a bad idea
to build a watch face
that only runs on square
and if round people install
it, it doesn't work.
People are going to
be upset, they're
going to write bad
reviews about your app.
So you really want to make
sure you cover both platforms.
And in some cases, like
an analog watch face,
if it's just got
some hands on it,
that'll work both on a
round and a square device.
In other cases you might
have to redesign the watch
face completely, because
square is very different.
The corners are present
whereas in a round watch
they're chopped off, so you
might need to deal with that.
Next Android Wear displays have
two modes that they run in.
There is an interactive
mode and an ambient mode.
So interactive mode is when
you're touching the screen,
and you're interacting
with the device,
you can actually
detect touches as well.
And this is the mode that's
used when the user's giving
their attention to the watch.
Now, the screen is
fully active, you
can have all the colors
and everything like that,
but after a short
period of idle time,
the watch goes
into what's called
ambient or always-on mode.
In this mode the screen
goes into a low power state,
it reduces the amount of
colors that are available,
and you should also
reduce the number
of pixels that are drawn
on the screen to save power
and to avoid burn.
And we'll talk about
that a bit more in a sec.
You'll see in this case
here, we have a watch face
on the left which is full color,
and then it in ambient mode,
it's just a black
screen with hands on it.
So you need to design your watch
face to run in both of these
modes, and you cannot render a
full colored image constantly
in ambient mode
when it's sleeping.
The watch won't allow that.
And secondly, the watch
face refreshes continuously
when you're in active mode.
But when your ambient mode,
the watch goes to sleep
and it only refreshes the
screen once every minute.
So you should remove
the second hand,
and you should only draw hours
and minutes, because we're
trying to save power.
So when the screen is an ambient
mode, the watch is not running.
It's actually asleep and
the only thing that's awake
is the display driver just
keeping that screen going.
So it's a great
way to save power,
and it means that you don't
have to flick your watch up
to look at the time.
The watch is always showing
the time, as you can see from,
as I'm walking around, this
watch never shuts down.
And that's one of the really
cool features of Android Wear,
is the screen is
running all the time.
Now, when we talk
about ambient mode,
we also need to deal with
how it's implemented.
So for example, certain
screens on Android Wear
are called lower bit screens
when they go into ambient mode,
they actually don't
allow full 24-bit color.
They only allow
primary red, green,
and blue colors, like only
certain colors are allowed.
You can't render shades
and all that kind of thing.
It's a feature of
the display driver
that allows it to save power.
Other displays go into
a black and white mode.
And some displays, such
as overhead displays,
actually require you
to only illuminate
5% of the pixels
in low power mode.
If you try to keep all the
pixels on the screen on all
the time, what will happen is
that over time, the screen will
burn in, and you'll
actually you'll
see the pixels permanently
burnt in to the screen.
And the other trick that
some of the displays do,
is they'll actually
take your watch face,
and every minute they would
jiggle it in a direction.
So they'll jiggle it 10
pixels in either direction,
and they use that to
help the watch face avoid
burning your screen in as well.
So you should never have
large patches of solid color
because they will eventually
burn into the screen,
and the jiggling can't
get around that either.
So definitely you want
to try to make sure
that you're careful about when
you design your ambient mode,
because you need to keep a lot
of the pixels off to save power
and to save the screen.
So, when you're
writing a watch face,
there is a class called
CanvasWatchFaceService.Engine
that you're going to be
sort of implementing here.
And inside of that
there's three methods.
So this onCreate,
which is where you're
going to take care of
initialization steps.
So one thing you want to
make sure you do here,
is you can have an image as the
background of your watch face,
but you've got to make
sure the scale the image
and do anything like
that in advance.
You don't want to be scaling
the image on every redraw
because it's very expensive.
You'll generate a lot
of memory and so forth.
So in onCreate you want to
do all of the initialization
steps.
The next thing is, there's a
method called onSurfaceChanged.
And onSurfaceChanged is
called when-- it announces
the size of the screen to you.
So this is where you
would deal with things
like resizing an image,
or anything, I guess
it's possible in the future
that a watch could rotate,
and if it rotates it would give
you an update onSurfaceChange.
So onSurfaceChange is
where you're notified
as to changes in the screen.
And then finally all
the drawing itself
is done in the onDraw method.
So this is the method that's
called by the Android Wear
system that says, draw
the watch right now.
And so you should be
doing no calendar queries,
you don't want to be
doing anything expensive,
everything has to be
fast here, and that's
where you draw everything.
And, if you want, you can
have an animated watch
face with smooth
ticking second hands.
So no ticking, it
will just smoothly
move by just repeatedly calling
onDraw over and over again.
And then you call an
invalidate method,
which then makes the
call onDraw repeatedly.
But you don't want to be
doing that kind of work
when you're in ambient
mode, because you
want the display
to sleep, and you
don't want to be
constantly hammering away
trying to refresh the screen.
So when you're in
ambient mode, your app
needs to stop doing things.
You don't want to
be doing too many--
you don't want to
be doing any work.
You want to be sleeping while
the watch is an ambient mode.
So that's watch faces.
Now let's talk about how we
go about actually building
apps and making them
work on Android Wear.
So Android Wear
devices are actually
complete Android
implementations.
They have everything.
They have open OpenGl.
They have all of the activities
and frameworks and everything
that you've come to be used to
running regular Android apps.
Probably the only two
things that are missing
is that there's no video
codecs, and you don't have
direct access to the internet.
So you can't make HTTP
request to a web server
and you're not able to play
video back on the screen.
The codecs have been removed
to save power and battery
and space on the device.
And you also probably
shouldn't be playing videos
on Android Wear device as well.
If you're looking at something
for 30 seconds on the screen
like watching a
video, you probably
should be pulling your
phone out of your pocket
and looking at it
on a regular screen.
So certain things you really
don't want to be doing.
And Android Wear devices
are very powerful
and they're capable of doing
pretty much anything you
can throw at them.
The only difference is
the way they're packaged.
And so the way it
works is that you
build a wearable APK that's
going to be installed
to the Android Wear device.
But the wearable APK is not
sent directly to the wearable.
What you do is you take the
wearable APK that you've built
and you put it
inside the phone APK.
You put it in the res/raw
directory basically.
When it's in the
res/raw directory,
you declare an XML file
and then you put it
inside the main
phone APK and you
push that phone APK
to the Play Store.
When the user downloads
that phone APK, it arrives
on their phone, and then the
wearable companion app goes,
oh, there's a
wearable app in here.
It takes that and installs
it onto your wearable,
and then it installs
and it's ready to go.
So the nice thing
about Android Wear
is that over time, as different
companies add Wear support
to their apps, your customers
just kind of get it for free.
They don't need to go out of
their way to download a new app
or to go and check any
boxes or do anything.
It just happens automatically.
That's the great
thing about Wear,
is it's very easy for
customers to deal with.
So, one final thing is that when
you update your app to the Play
Store, you bump
the version codes,
you push it on to
the Play Store,
and then it downloads
to the phone.
And the phone goes ah, there's
a new version of the app.
I'll push it to the
wearable as well.
So as a little
tip, very important
that you get the version codes
on the wearable and phone sides
to be the same.
They have to have the
same package name,
otherwise they won't be
able to talk to each other.
So in Gradle, in Android
Studio, we have a wearApp.
So you'll see this in the build
doc Gradle for the application.
It'll say wearApp
project brackets wear.
And what that says is,
take the wearable project,
compile it, and
then bring that APK
and put it inside the phone app.
So it actually takes
care of all this for you.
So when you're building
in release mode,
the wearable APK's embedded
into the phone APK, just
takes care of it for you.
And a lot of our samples
implement this as well,
so you can see how it's done.
So let's talk now about things
that are wearable specific.
So while they are
complete Android devices
and they implement
everything that you've
seen on Android before, so
you can reuse your same skills
and knowledge,
there's a few things
in Android Wear that
are different that you
need to be aware of.
So the rest of the
talk is going to be
talking about those things.
So we're going to
talk about sharing
data between the
wearable and the phone,
we're going to talk about
building custom user
interfaces, and I'm
going to finish up
by talking quickly about how we
implement voice interactions.
So, as I said
before Android Wear
devices don't have
direct network access.
You'll sometimes season that
Android Wear devices support
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth and if the
Android Wear devices connected
in a certain way by Wi-Fi
sometimes there's access,
but you can't rely
on that behavior.
The only way to get proper
connectivity between the phone
and the wearable is to use
what we call the data API
and message API and so forth.
And what they do is they allow
the wearable and the phone
to talk to each other,
and then the phone
can go and do the
network access for you.
So if your wearable app
needs to go and find out
what the weather
is, the wearable app
will send a message to
the phone app saying,
hey, tell me the
current weather.
The phone will then make an HTTP
request to a weather website.
It'll download the
weather information.
It'll then go, ah, the
temperature today is 56.
It'll then take that number,
send it over as a message
to the wearable, and
the wearable onDraw it.
You don't want the wearable
doing lots of heavy work.
If the wearable is able
to make an HTTP request,
you don't want it sitting
there making the query,
pausing all the HTML
and cleaning it all up.
You don't want the wearable
doing these kind of things.
So that's important.
And this communication
mechanism is implemented
by Google Play services.
So Play services
provides the framework
that allows these devices
to talk to each other,
and they're done by
asynchronous calls.
So we're going to go through
now how to go about doing this.
So there are three kinds of
data exchange that are possible.
The first one is the node
API, and what this does
is it tells you when two
devices are connected.
So if a wearable and a phone
appear close to each other,
then the node API
will say Yeah a device
has just become connected.
And if the wearable goes
off for a walk or the phone
goes for a walk, then you'll
get a disconnect message
so that you know that they're
no longer paired to each other.
We have the message API,
which allows you to exchange
low latency messages.
So these are messages where the
phone might say, hey, wearable,
make a noise or do
something right now,
and the wearable will do it.
However, if the wearable
is disconnected,
that message will be lost.
So you only use messages
in cases when something
has to happen right now,
and if the message is lost,
it's no big deal.
So they're kind of
like UDP packets
when you're doing TCP/IP.
And then we also
have the data API.
The data API allows you to
create a key value object that
has something like, temperature
of 56, current weather raining.
You can put that in
an object and then
you can send it to all the
wearable devices on the network
and it'll automatically
synchronize it for you,
and you don't need to
worry about retransmitting.
If the wearable
is not connected,
when you bring it back
later on, the data items
will be synchronized up.
It takes care of all
those things for you,
so it's really nice.
And actually we have another
API, called the channel API,
which allows you to make
connections to a wearable
and send data over it so
you could stream some audio,
or something like that.
So there's a variety
of different APIs
that we provide to [INAUDIBLE]
communicate back and forth
from a phone to a wearable.
So to quickly walk through
it, this is the node API.
So you can see
here where there's
a getConnectedNodes method.
You call that, it returns you
a list of all the wearables
that are connected.
Important tip here is that
it's possible for users
to have many Android Wear
devices connected to a phone.
So when you get an array
back from that top call,
you should not just
read the first element.
You should read all of them
because some people like
me have eight Android
Wear devices at their desk
and I want all of them
to work all the time.
So make sure you code
that up for me, otherwise
my functionally won't work.
So yeah people could have
many Android by devices.
That's a very key
sort of mistake
that some people make, is
they don't do that right.
And then you simply
declare a node listener,
and you get these methods
that are called when peers
are connected or disconnected.
So the message API, we have
a method called sendMessage.
You simply pass in
the idea of the device
you want to send a message to.
You could pass it
in a string-- sorry,
you pass it in a byte array--
it sends it to the device.
And then you can
register a method
to be called on message
received if a message arrives
at your device.
And finally for the
data API, you've
got putDataItems
and getDataItems.
Those allow you to put
data items into the store,
they're synchronized
back and forth,
and then you can
retrieve them back
if messages are sent to you.
And then there's
onDataChanged, which
is called whenever an item
has arrived off the network.
So, it's a very simple
API, and it helps deal
with all the complexities of
sending data back and forth
between wearables and phones.
And finally there
is a base class
called WearableListenerService
that you implement,
which is what you put all
those other methods in to.
And you have to declare it in
your AndroidManifest XML file.
And that tells
Google Play services
that it is allowed to send
these messages and data
items to your app, to
allow them to communicate
with the wearable.
So that's basically it for
sending data back and forth.
So it's a very
powerful API, and it's
how communications are done.
And as I said before,
make sure the package
names and the version
codes and all that match
between the wearable and
the phone application,
otherwise they won't be
able to talk to each other.
And it's not possible to
send data items or messages
to a different app on
the system that doesn't
match your package then.
You'll have to come up with
some other mechanism to do that.
So we've talked about
sending data, now
let's talk about how
to build custom user
interfaces on Android Wear.
Because while Android
Wear is based on Android,
if you actually look at the
user interface on the screen,
it doesn't look a
lot like Android.
It looks very different.
The interface has
been designed to look
great on wearables in
outdoor environments
when you're walking around.
So to do this, we
provide a library
called the wearable support
library to help out with this.
So in your Gradle file,
it's called com.google.andro
id.support:wearable, and this
is what we call the wearable
support library.
So this wearable
support library provides
functionality that's specific
to Android Wear devices
but that doesn't belong in
the Android framework itself.
So when we designed
Android Wear we
want to have a common
experience across the platform
so that apps look the same.
So we wanted the
system apps, and apps
written by developers like
you, to have a consistent look
and feel.
And so this library contains
reusable UI elements
that you can use in your
code, to make your life easier
so you don't have to
reinvent the wheel.
So we use this
library for our apps
as well, and so
if you've actually
got any ideas for things
that are like you know,
I really wish I had
a widget to do blah,
you know, please come and tell
me or one of the developer
advocates because
we'd like to hear
more feedback about the
kind of things people want.
So what is the wearable support
library and how does it work?
It's different than the
Android support library.
So you might be familiar
with Android support library.
That is used to sort of
backport new Android features
to old releases.
The wearable support
library is different.
It's designed as a
general support library
that, these are things
that might never
make in the
framework, but they're
useful for designing
wearable apps.
The next thing is that
it's compiled statically
into your app.
So if you do use the
wearable support library,
the code is going
to be in your APK.
It's not part of
the system itself.
So your APK is going to get a
little larger when you use it.
Now you can strip
out the parts you
don't need with resource
minification and proguard,
but just be aware that
that has to be done.
So it doesn't have a
huge impact on APK.
The actual library
itself is quite small,
so it won't cause too
much flood in your APK.
But it's something to be aware
of if you're working with it.
It's also released
at different cycles
that are independent of
the Android framework.
So the Android framework is like
Marshmallow, Lollipop, KitKat,
things like that.
The wearable support library
is independent of that.
It typically is released
whenever any Android Wear
release comes out.
So it's not-- changes
to the wearable support
library are not dependent
on new APIs coming out.
So that's nice.
So we can add new features and
we can fix bugs very quickly.
And this library
though, because it
is a new library that
statically linked in,
the API actually could change
a little bit between versions.
So there's a
possibility that if you
bump to a different
version, you might
have to tweak your
code a little bit.
But you can always
use the old version
if that's what you want.
So you need to be aware of the
fact that the API could change
and it might break
backwards compatibility.
So it's not like the
Android framework
in that we guarantee
that it's going
to work till forever, the
wearable support library will
evolve over time.
So how do we go about using it?
So when you're
building-- will start,
when you're writing
your buildup writeup
file on the wearable
side, you've
got the dependency section.
So if you look at
the bottom, you
can see it's got
play-services-wearable.
So some of you may have used
Google Play services before,
that's a pretty standard line
that you include that says
give me play-services-wearble.
Play services has actually
been broken up into pieces
so that you can select
which parts of play service
you want to import.
Because play services
is a very large library,
and you don't want to import
all of that into your app.
By just adding
play-services-wearable,
we are saying I just
want the data API
and I just want the message
API and things like that.
The wearable support
libraries is the top line,
so we've said OK
com.google.andro
id.support:wearable
include that library,
and then we have
a plus at the end.
Now some people would
say you should never
use plus because what it
does it grabs the latest
version of the wearable
support library.
So you could be in the
middle of a release
and then that day
Google releases
a new version of the
wearable support library
and you are like why
is my build broken,
and it's because you said
grab the latest version.
So if you want stability
with your builds,
you should hard code
in the version number.
So if you look on the Play
Services at the bottom,
I've got colon 8.1.0.
And that says use
version 8.1.0, and I
don't care what the
newest version is,
you must use that version.
So right now wearable
support is 1.3
but you can hard code that
depending on what you want to
I have some test samples that
I use that have a plus in them,
because I want to always
test with the latest version
to see what's going on.
But you can control
what happens here.
But it's very important
that you understand
the implications of plus
versus a version number.
And this is a common
thing you need
to understand when
you're writing
any kind of Android app.
And finally the middle
line that says provided.
That is needed for when
you're implementing
the always-on mode.
We have a special
library that helps out.
You'll need to
include that line.
I way gone into too
much detail on that,
but that's also
important as well.
So when we introduced
Android Wear,
one of the big differences was
that it had a round screen.
So up until then, every computer
and everything we've ever had
has been square
rectangular displays.
So the introduction
of a round display
is really beautiful as you can
see from these watches here,
but it imposes
challenges for developers
because people haven't thought
about round screens before.
So widgets we're using
like textview and things
like that, they don't
understand round screens.
So we need to help
developers understand
how to deal with round screens
and what we can do about it.
So if you look on the left,
you've got the Moto 360.
That actually has an
inset at the bottom
or what some people call
a chin or a flat tire,
which is 30 pixels in size.
You've then got the next watch,
which is a square screen, even
though it looks rounded.
The next one is a round
screen with no inset,
and then finally the last one
is a rectangular screen as well.
So, we need to
write software that
works on all of these screens.
So if we want to
create a text view
and put a large amount
of text on the screen,
what would happen?
On the far right
you can see we've
got a regular rectangular
screen, the text fits nicely.
However, on the
round screen, you
can see the top, bottom,
right, left, everything is all
chopped off.
So you can't read
all of the text.
It would be a really bad
idea to throw a pile of text
on the screen and
not do anything
about it because all
of your round customers
are going to have a bad time.
And there are a lot of Android
Wear round devices out there.
So if you only
designed to square
you're not going to do well.
People are not going
to like your app.
So what can we do about this?
So wearable support
library provides
three different classes that
you can use to help out here.
We've got BoxInsetLayout,
WearableFrameLayout
and WatchViewStub.
We're going to go
through each of them,
to show how to use them.
So the first one
BoxInsetLayout, what it does
is it adds padding around
the edges of your text view
to prevent the
text from touching
the edges of the screen.
So you can see on the left
the BoxInsetLayout has added
padding all around it, so
that the text never touches
the round edge of the display.
So we can read the
text, it looks nice,
and that's quite cool.
So how do we go about
implementing this?
And finally,
actually before we do
that, if you look on
the square screen,
it's exactly the same as before.
So we're using all of the
space of a square screen
but on the round screen
we're making it fit.
So how do we go
about doing this?
What we do is in our layout XML
file, we have at the very top,
where's my laser I put it
away-- there it is anyway,
if you look at the top,
there's box inset layout
can people see the cursor?
No.
Nope, my cursor is not working.
If you look at the
top there, we've
got at the top
level of hierarchy,
we have a box inset layout.
The box inset layout
contains the text view.
And then inside the text view
we've defined an attribute app
layout_box="all".
And what that says is we're
living inside a box inset
layout and I want to be
boxed on all four sides
to do the implementation.
And if you actually forget to
put that in, it won't be boxed.
So it's very important that
you actually remember to put it
inside a box inset layout and
also to set the attribute app
layout_box="all."
Now you could also, you don't
have to box around everything,
you can actually box
just the left and right.
So for example here you can see
the text is boxed on your left
and right, and it's
allowed to flow completely
to the top and bottom
parts of the screen.
And implementation for this,
is we simply replace the word
all with left and right.
And you could also do
top and bottom as well,
same here, you can see the
effect on the round screen.
Typically you don't want to
always do a complete all box
in.
What you might want to
do is have it boxed just
on the left and
the right and then
have it scrollable because
the middle part of the screen
is still quite usable, but
you don't want a box it
all completely,
otherwise you waste
a lot of screen real estate.
So you want to squeeze
it much otherwise you are
going to read much text at all.
And so here's how we
do the top and bottom.
Now finally, one thing
you will notice here
is that when you put a text
view inside a box inset layout,
the green background extends
all the way to the edges.
Now you might want
to-- so the way
it works is that the
margins of the text view
are adjusted but not
the entire view itself.
So if you actually want to force
the view to fit completely,
and have a black background
or whatever the default is,
you can actually put a whole
lot inside of a frame layout
container and then put the frame
layout container inside the box
inset layout.
And so that's one
of the things you
can do with it, if you want
the black border instead.
You might want to have
other things appearing
in those corners, and this
will allow you to do that.
So while BoxInsetLayout is easy
to use-- you simply just add it
to your layout hierarchy and
it boxes everything for you,
pretty much automatically--
it's not very efficient,
as we pointed out earlier.
So there must be better
ways of dealing with this.
So in one of the recent
wearable support libraries
we added something called
WearableFrameLayout,
and what this does is it
allows you to specify padding,
an attributes for things
like centering or alignment,
but you can specify different
attributes depending on if it's
a round or a square device.
So you can see here,
on the round display,
I've got the green
boxes centered.
I wanted 25dp margins.
And then on square, I
want it to be left aligned
with 5dp margins.
And you can see that
they look very different
on the round versus square,
but the implementation
is quite easy.
So if you look here, in
the WearableFrameLayout
you can see we have
layout_gravityRound
is centered, but layout_gravity
the default version
is going to be the left aligned
whatever the default is.
And you can see every time
we've thrown a round keyword
into the attribute,
WearableFrameLayout
looks at round or
not round to work out
what it's going to do for
your particular device.
So everything we just showed
in that previous example
is encoded here.
So the nice thing is that
you can have one single XML
file that does layouts
for round and square,
you can maintain them together.
And it helps sort of to simplify
the process of-- one problem
that people commonly do
is they define a round
and a square layout, and
they change the square layout
and they forget to
update the round layout
and they've got
bugs in on round.
So this helps to
avoid that problem.
So finally, we have what's
called WatchViewStub, which
is a class that
allows you to inflate
two separate layouts that
depend on whether your on round
or square.
So you can see in
this case here,
the layouts are
completely different.
One of them has a gradient,
and the other one has a circle.
They're totally nothing
to do with each other
and that WatchViewStub inflates
the correct layout depending
on which one you want.
So if you look here,
the implementation
is WatchViewStub, two
layout definitions,
and those layouts are
defined in separate files.
So the nice thing
here is that you
get full control of
everything, there's
no need to worry about trying
to express both layouts in one
file.
But the con of it all is that
you have to have two files,
and you must remember
to update both of them
and test on both
round and square
whenever you make a change.
Because you get that wrong,
then you'll have a problem.
So those are sort of the
pros and cons of the three
different ways you
can use, depending
on what your app looks
like and which one you
choose will very much depend
on the app that you're writing.
So that's a quick
little rundown of what's
available to support
round versus square.
So what else in the
wearable support library?
So here's a list of all
the different classes that
are available in
there as of now,
and I'm quickly going to
walk through them to show you
a few things that are available
in case you weren't aware
of it.
So the first thing we have,
is that a lot of Android Wear
apps have the ability to
show cards on the screen,
and they also use this swiping
kind of interface where
you can swipe sideways
to see different actions,
you can scroll up and down,
so there's actually something
called GridViewPager which
implements this ability
to create a bunch of
fragments and then
you can scroll up
and down through them
and it implements the smooth
scrolling effect that you
see on this example here.
And this image actually is taken
from one of our samples coat
XYZ tourist attractions.
The next thing is,
is DotsPageIndicator,
which if you look
at the very bottom
there are five little dots
that as we swipe sideways
you can see those dots changing.
That's the dots
page indicator that
shows you which page you're on.
So we've written code that
provides this for you,
so you don't need to worry
about writing this kind of thing
yourself.
Next we have ActionPage, which
you saw in the previous example
where we were picking actions.
ActionPage is the full screen
button with circular text
that you see there.
So most Android Wear
notifications and apps
use this kind of button with
a little pingie in the middle
to express things,
and people are used
to seeing these kind of things.
So if you use this it
does all work for you
of handling the button
press and laying it out
and it also gives
you a ripple feedback
when you press it and it
has an action label that
adjusts in size
depending on your screen
so that it always fits.
So it's kind of nice, and it
gives you the functionality
that you've seen in
other apps without having
to write it yourself.
Next we have DismissOverlayView.
It's a common paradigm
in Android Wear apps
that you want to exit something,
you actually press and hold
on the app and a
red X will pop up.
You then press the
X to exit the app.
So we've provided
the functionality
that allows you to do this.
So it gives you this pop up
that offers to let you quit out.
So here it is in operation, and
then here's the code to do it.
Now, actually, when you use
this DismissOverlayView,
you need to suppress the
ability to swipe the app away.
So on Android
Wear, you typically
have the ability to grab
the app and flick it
to the right, which
will exit the app.
If you're using the
DismissOverlayView to exit out,
you don't need that swipe
away gesture anymore.
You might want to be making,
for example, a map out
where you need to use the
finger to scroll around a map.
You don't want the user to swipe
to the right to kill your app,
you want to use it to
swipe map to the right.
So in this code
here, you can see
how we're creating a new custom
theme which actually disables
window swipe to dismiss
and set it to false,
and then in your
manifest file, you
pick the theme that you just
created that suppresses swipe
to the right.
Next we have WearableListView.
You may have seen on
Android Wear the ability
to select from options, like
the settings area uses it,
the app launch uses it, it's
a pretty common concept,
so we've provided this
functionality so that you
can provide some colors,
and some images, and text,
and you can swipe up
and down through it.
So this is very
common usage pattern,
you write an adapter for it
and that's available as well.
Let's just wait till
we get to the end.
We're almost done.
Then we can go through it.
We had DelayedConfirmationView.
So when you send a text message
on Android Wear, you say,
send a message, I made
a reservation at 7:30.
It then brings up
this dialogue that
shows a ticking down timer that
shows that it's about to do it.
So the nice thing about
this, is if the user does
nothing the message is sent.
But if the user realizes
the message is incorrect
they can cancel it.
So it was actually a nice way
of saying, instead of saying,
are you sure you
want to send this
it's I'm going to send this
unless you tell me not to.
Just DelayedConfirmationView
helps with making that easier.
So it uses the so-called image
you for the implementation
of the circle and that provides
the set progress in the timer
countdown as well.
And to use-- we have
another thing called
a ConfirmationActivity, which
is after the message has been
sent, you can actually
pop up a green check box
to say it was done.
So the green check box is
actually an animated vector
drawable that appears, and
you can use this code here,
where you can start an activity
which brings this confirmation
activity up on the screen.
So you've seen all of
these different things
appear in Android Wear
apps, this is how it's done.
Also we have a CircledImageView
and a CircularButton.
These are two different sort of
more little clickable widgets
that you can use if you
want to implement pop up
boxes that show various things.
So these are all useful
for different kinds of apps
that people might want to make.
And remember, also to use
very large touch targets.
You see those things
are very large
compared to the size of the
emulator window I use there.
You can only fit about
for those on the screen.
You want to make sure
they're really big.
You don't want to have
40 of these buttons
on there, because
no one's going to go
to press their finger
on it accurately
to be able to press it.
Finally, we have what's called
a RemoteInputIntent where
you can actually start an
activity that brings up
this RemoteInputIntent,
and it allows
you to take advantage of
the speech recognition
engine of Android Wear.
So you can see there
it says Speak now,
you can speak whatever
you want, it'll
transcribe the text for it and
it will then return a string
back to your app.
Alternatively you and press
Draw emoji and you draw an emoji
and it'll send you back the
emoji as a string as well.
So you can actually use
emoji's and speech in your app
without having to implement
all that stuff yourself.
And Android Wear has a
really cool emoji recognizer
that you can use, and you
don't have to write any of it
yourself.
So that's really nice.
So that was a quick
rundown of some
of the key features of
Android Wear that are
very important to writing apps.
So let's just
finish up by talking
about Voice Actions, which
are key part of the platform.
So as we mentioned
earlier, we have
this concept at Android
Wear of OK Google
take a note, book me a
ride, send a message, things
like that.
Those are system provided
actions that are task based,
they're built into
the Android Wear
platform and their specified
with an intent filter.
And you can actually look
into those if you want.
So if you have an app that
implements take a note,
you can write an app
that takes notes.
However, if you've
written an app that
doesn't fit into any of the
existing tasks that are built
into Android Wear,
you can also--
the user can say OK Google,
start app name, where
app name is the name
of your app as it's
declared as a launcher icon
in the AndroidManifest XML.
So you can see here,
you've got fitkeep
and-- can't read the last
one-- WhatsApp or something.
You can say, OK,
Google, start keep,
and it'll bring the app up.
So this is the way that your app
can always be launched easily.
The user can use their
finger to launch your app,
but they can also
speak it as well.
And then finally, we have
the speech recognizer
that we showed earlier, and
that was the RemoteInputIntent.
You can use that as well.
So those are sort of the
main ways you interact
with Android Wear device.
It's not just about
touching on the screen.
It's about speech
recognition and not
thinking about your
apps in terms of apps,
but thinking about them in
terms of tasks that they solve.
Users want to take notes.
They don't want to
launch a note-taking app.
And there's a different in
how you understand that.
These are actually a list of
the actions that are currently
in Android Wear, so
you can see there's
a whole bunch of different
things that you can do here
and those can change over time.
So there you have it.
So this is a summary
of the different things
you can use to go about
creating Android Wear apps,
and the different
things you can do.
So we actually have
a code lab that's
starting at 12:45
I believe, where
the code lab is all about
creating your own watch
face for Android Wear.
So you can show up, we
have a starting sample,
you can drag your own image in,
and you can create a watch face
with a custom picture of your
dog or your cat or whatever.
And it's a really
cool way of just sort
of seeing how quickly
you can get started
with Android Wear and emulator.
And if you don't have
one you definitely
need to go out and get one.
They're really cool devices and
lots of apps on the Play Store
now support them, and there's
a lot of functionality
that's sort of interesting
for developers.
And it's a great way of
differentiating your app.
Because there's a
lot of apps out there
that if you have a really great
Android Wear implementation,
that might be the
thing that makes
your app popular
amongst people and helps
you to get a bit of a
foothold with more customers.
So if you want to learn
more, we have a whole bunch
of documentation on
developer.android.com/wear.
We have design guidelines
on developer.androi
d.com/design/wear where
we sort of talk about more
of the design methodology and
how to make really beautiful
apps.
Google really cares
about design right now,
and so it's really important
that you make nice apps that
look really good.
Don't just take old apps
and sort of squeeze them on
to the wearable display.
You'll really think
about the user,
and do a really
nice job about it.
So I post a whole bunch
of stuff on G+ constantly.
So I'm one of the main developer
advocates for Android Wear,
so every week or so I put out
tips and so forth about how
to best take advantage
of the platforms, things
I've discovered, new releases.
So please find me on Google+ if
you're interested in learning
more about the things that I do.
And I said I talk about
Android Wear a lot,
but we also took Android Auto
and Ubiquitous Computing.
And also I will put my biscuits
and gravy recipe up on G+
as well.
So go check that out.
So thanks very much for
coming and thanks a lot
and I'm happy to talk
to you all later.
Thank you.
And I guess we've got a
few minutes for questions
if anyone wants to ask anything.
You got a question?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So I have question is when, when
we do action button on the Wear
we slide and then you push
button on the quick view,
but to send the data the signal
to the wearable alone or it
will send the data
[INAUDIBLE] to the mobile app
or it will be able
to do both anyhow?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
So the question was
is that when you press like
an action label or a button
or something like that
will the press, which
is will the press get
sent to the phone as well
as the wearable.
And the answer is no.
So if the wearable created
these buttons and widgets,
the callbacks or
whatever are only
sent to the wearable itself.
If you want the wearable to
send something to the phone,
you to send a message or a data
item or something like that.
Now, in the case
of notifications,
if you create a
notification on the phone,
the notification
appears on the wearable,
if you click on to the actions,
that will get sent back
to the phone.
So that's only done in the
case of a notification,
and it's only done in the
case of if the notification is
created on the phone.
It's actually possible to create
notifications on the wearable,
those are not sent
back to the phone.
So yeah typically,
the wearable never
sends anything back,
except for notification
created on the phone
AUDIENCE: And is there any
way we make it to send back
or it's just--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: You have to
write that mechanism yourself.
So if you want to
send something back,
you do a data item or
a message or a channel
and then you can send
it back that way.
Next question
AUDIENCE: One question, when we
use the message API or the data
API, for devices that
support Wi-Fi they connect
through the Cloud right?
Is there any way to
prevent that behavior?
Like if we only want to send
messages or data items, only
if they are connected
through Bluetooth,
to avoid sending
data to the Cloud.
Like I mean for a big
companies important to have
your data like secure right,
and we don't want to send data--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I mean
there's a-- in the node API,
there's something
you can, there's
a method-- can't
remember the name of it.
But it basically is
local or something.
So you can ask for
a list of devices,
and then you can,
for each device,
you can say is it local or not,
and that then would tell you
if it's connected
via local pairing,
or if it's still available but
it's connected by the Cloud
somehow.
So that could be a way that
you could avoid sending it
through the cloud like that.
But I mean, I guess
there's a possibility
that it could switch from
Bluetooth so Wi-Fi mode
and you could send
a message just
as it's making the
transition so there's
no way to mark a
message as do not ever
send this to the Cloud.
The same time though messages
in the Cloud are not stored,
they're just sent--
AUDIENCE: I'm worried
about the data API,
because data API, normally you
push things into the network
and then it gets synced
across all the clients.
But because the Cloud knows
it's part of that network,
there is no way to prevent
that data to actually go
to the Cloud, but you still
want that syncing behavior,
but only if they are connected.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: In
the case of data items,
the thing is when you create
data items, synchronized
all devices automatically,
I don't think there's a way
to prevent that from happening.
If it was really
important to you,
I guess you could encrypt it.
You'd have to do something
about that yourself,
there's nothing to support that.
Any other questions?
Yeah-- Do you want
to grab the mic?
AUDIENCE: So I have an LG
Urbane watch [INAUDIBLE].
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I have
an LG Urbane watch.
So that has like a standalone
Wi-Fi in that watch.
So whenever I make
a headphone request
when it is not connected
to my phone via Bluetooth,
it works fine.
But when it is connected
to my phone via Bluetooth,
the Wi-Fi is
automatically disabled.
So basically I cannot make a
network call if it's connected
to Bluetooth via
Wi-Fi [INAUDIBLE].
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: You
can't make a call?
What?
AUDIENCE: Like network call.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: A network call.
AUDIENCE: Like via Wi-Fi.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK I mean
the thing is, the Wi-Fi--
AUDIENCE: Is it specifically
designed like that?
Or like, what's the
use case for that?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah so
the Wi-Fi feature is, it
uses more power than Bluetooth.
So we want to keep
Wi-Fi off when possible.
So if everything's
working over Bluetooth,
we will send things
over Bluetooth.
Now I think what you're
asking is, is you've
got an app that's running
on your watch that's
trying to make HTTP requests.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
So you're not
supposed to do that.
So if you want to do network
requests from the watch,
you're relying on
behavior that's not really
supposed to be used, so what
are you trying to request.
AUDIENCE: I was trying to
develop some feature actually.
I was trying to Wi-Fi--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah
it kind of works,
the problem is you can't
keep the Wi-Fi feature on.
You don't get to control that.
So if Bluetooth is available,
it'll switch to Bluetooth.
So the correct way to deal
with what you're trying to do,
is if you really want to make
an arbitrary HTTP request.
So if you want to
check the weather,
send a message to the phone,
the phone gets the weather,
and then you pause the
HTML, you extract out
the temperature information,
send it as a data item.
AUDIENCE: So all the
network operation
should be done
within the phone app
and the data should be passed to
either the data API or message
API.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah
and that will work.
Now if you really
wanted to get dirty,
say the dirty solution
is you send a data
item to the phone that says
HTTP://weather.com blah, blah,
blah.
And then the reply is the entire
HTTP response as a string,
and then the wearable
could do all of it.
So you can write yourself a
really cheapy little proxy
over data items that
go back and forth.
Or you could use a channel
API, but you're really not
supposed to be doing that.
You're going to
be doing it wrong
and you're going to be
wasting a lot of power.
So that's the
solution if you really
wanted to be lazy about it.
But the best solution is,
get the phone to do the work
and strip the data down
into its simplest form,
and then send it
back to the wearable.
OK, I think we're out of time
so we do have a code lab,
remember at 12:45.
And actually my
colleague Michael Kwan,
he's giving a talk
at 12:00, I think?
He's giving a
talk, he's actually
one of the engineers
on Android Wear.
He did a lot of work
on power optimization
and looking for bugs, and
he's a fantastic engineer,
so you definitely, if you are
interested in Android Wear,
you definitely hear
Michael's talk as well.
Otherwise I'll be around a 12:45
at the code lab room talking
about Android Wear watch faces.
Feel free to come and talk to
us then or during the barbecue
afterwards and thanks a
lot and I'll see you later.
Thanks.